- Une étoile est née.
Le nom de Leylah Fernandez
est sur toutes les lèvres
depuis quelques jours.
Cette demi-finale aux
Internationaux des États-Unis,
la Québécoise y rêve
depuis toujours.
Son père, qui a immigré
de l'Équateur, s'est entièrement
dédié à la carrière de sa fille.
Il est devenu son entraîneur,
même s'il n'avait aucune
expérience dans le domaine.
- C'est bien, ça! C'est très
bien!
- Les sacrifices ont donc été
nombreux pour la famille
Fernandez.
JORGE FERNANDEZ,
père de Leylah Fernandez
- On n'a pas de REER, on n'a pas
de maison, on a rien,
honnêtement. T'sais, ce qu'on a,
on l'a dévoué dans le tennis.
- Ils auront finalement eu
raison de croire en Leylah. Dès
les rangs junior, la Lavalloise
a cumulé les exploits. En 2019,
elle a été finaliste aux
Internationaux d'Australie
avant d'être sacrée championne
à Roland-Garros.
En mars dernier, elle a
remporté un premier titre
sur le circuit de la WTA
à Monterrey à l'âge de 18 ans
seulement.
Après avoir vaincu
la troisième joueuse mondiale,
Naomi Osaka, et l'ancienne
numéro un mondiale, Angelique
Kerber, Leylah Fernandez
a éliminé, mardi,
la cinquième tête de série,
Elina Svitolina, pour se
retrouver dans le carré d'as.
Grâce à son talent, sa ténacité
et son charisme, Leylah
Fernandez est rapidement devenue
la coqueluche de la foule
new-yorkaise.
L'ascension de Leylah Fernandez
est fulgurante. Avant les
Internationaux des États-Unis,
elle était classée 73e joueuse
mondiale. Avec sa participation
à la demi-finale, elle est
maintenant assurée d'atteindre
au moins le 36e rang
au classement de la WTA.
Un autre défi de taille attend
maintenant la Québécoise alors
qu'elle affrontera, jeudi,
la deuxième joueuse mondiale,
Aryna Sabalenka.
Chez les hommes,
Félix Auger-Aliassime sera aussi
des demi-finales : une première
en carrière pour le Québécois
de 21 ans. Il y aura donc
deux Québécois en demi-finales
d'un tournoi du Grand Chelem :
un moment historique
pour le tennis canadien.
Ici Christine Roger,
Radio-Canada, M